um you know i'm disappointed in myself
and
embarrassed and frustrated but at the
end of the day you know we won and
uh luckily you guys are happy going home
you know i had some confidence that
steven
regardless of what happened before guys
made a ton of kicks in his career and um
you know really no question she needs to
make that
he's been a great kicker in this league
for a long time so you know everybody
has adversity
you know he's gonna come over there and
um you know facilitate the end i'm very
confident that that'll uh get corrected
but again like i said earlier
it's not all one guy
you know whether there's some push or
the snap we got to make them that whole
operation
you know that was one of the keys to the
game
various faces and voices in the
aftermath of last night's tennessee win
16-14 over the broncos when derek henry
said everybody has adversity i thought
his next line was going to be
steven guskowski just happened to have
all of his on the same night
because i mean
multiple missed kicks three field goals
one was blocked two were missed an extra
point was missed to the point where
a chip shot game winner at the end of
regulation was viewed as anything but a
chip shot i think the titans ideally
wanted to score the touchdown so they
didn't have to
suffer through a 25-yard attempt it did
go through that did provide the margin
chris but
i don't know how a kicker recovers from
that many misses yes you got the win
but you shouldn't have had to win by
only two it should have been an easy
comfortable margin this is the flip side
of the early game the early game was a
10-point margin but the game was a lot
closer this was a two-point margin and
the game wasn't that close and it
shouldn't have been that close well no i
mean it shouldn't but this is also a
little bit you know this is a you know
red zone issues and if you're gonna play
this style of football where sometimes
it's a little bit of like hey we're
content on being a little ben don't
break on defense we're gonna chew up the
clock and we're just gonna wear you down
and be efficient that way yeah when you
have days like that where your field
goal kicker's off or whatever all of a
sudden you look up and you go man we've
controlled the football game which the
tennessee titans did for the most part
last night and you go whoa we're down in
the fourth quarter uh so that's that's
kind of the
the bad of the style of play they play
as far as in tennessee guskowski i think
he'll at least be able to like
you know you make the game winner
hopefully that'll give him some
confidence he can
realistically say hey i missed the 47
yarder in the first quarter okay it's
first field goal of the year it's 47
yards it's not exactly easy
but you know the other missed field goal
in the third quarter
and the missed extra point yeah they're
concerning and this is one of the
greatest kickers of all time i mean he
was like
knock him down
bullseye every time up in new england
for like almost his whole career so
we'll see he is one of those kickers i
think mike that you maybe give a little
time to because of his history and his
clutchness but if he has another week
like that or another two shaky weeks
they might be this might be like last
year for them where they're back to the
drawing board in the kicking department
and trying to find the right guy
i just can't help but wonder and i know
it's been more than four years now i
can't help but wonder whether
every time he's back
in that stadium back in denver
he thinks back to the missed extra point
in the first half of the afc
championship game 2015 what the
implications of that were later in the
game and i know you technically have to
go back to that point and replay the
game because it's a different mindset if
that point goes through and the game is
in position to be tied and you know
regardless yeah yeah they could have had
three super bowl wins in a row and if
i'm stephen guskowski at some point in
the last five years i have contemplated
the reality that my missed extra point
in denver
kept my team from winning three super
bowls in a row so anytime i'm back at
that stadium
i'm gonna have a hell of a time putting
the ball between the goal posts yeah
well
i'll say this there's certain stadiums
that
don't sit well with players right i mean
brady you could say that's the same
thing about him up in denver too but but
i would also argue that that defense is
damn well they have something to say
about it but but i do think there is
something to that like do i think that
might have crossed his brain at some
point in pregame or getting off the bus
that day i wouldn't be shocked that's
how football players work even kickers
which i'm not sure if we qualify them as
football players or not but yes i know
it was a cheap shot of the kickers i'm
sorry about that but i'm not that sorry
but i think there is something like you
i know in my limited experience and i've
had these conversations with other
players my father there are certain
stadiums you go in and whatever it is it
just looks like man this i feel good in
this stadium the sight lines the way the
stands sit you know the field just seems
right i'd get on certain fields and go
it doesn't seem like this field's 100
yards i feel like i could throw the ball
like the distance of the field and then
i'd get to another stadium and go man i
just i i can't quite see the distance of
the receivers the quite way and it makes
you uncomfortable and maybe that is one
of these places for goskowski but uh
they got to get that fixed because
that's the way style football they play
they need to depend on their field goal
when you want to play defense slug it
out run game type of football mike
verbal style uh it's an important part
of their football team
and it undermined the performance of
derek henry who had 31 carries for 116
yards and seven other touches in the
passing game earning his money and it
undermined i think the reality that
brian tannehill there's something
different about him now yeah maybe maybe
it's what he did last year comeback
player of the year was he the comeback
player of the year i always forget those
awards all i care about the end of the
day is the super bowl yeah yeah well he
came back from oh that was shereen
williams argument and coming back from
stinking should not become back player
of the year she said that not me she's
got texas a m license to say that
but he looks different maybe it's the
contract that pays out 118 million over
four years more than patron home is
going to make over the next four years
more than desean watson is going to make
over the next four years but he was
carrying himself differently and i agree
mike derrick henry's been doing yeah and
he continued that run and ryan tannehill
continued that performance from last
year and it's all overshadowed by the
idiot kicker
and i don't mean he's an idiot but
that's just
you know we could say liquored up kicker
too that was a peyton manning phrase i'm
not suggesting
but ryan tannehill ryan tannehill
eight years after being drafted has
finally arrived well yes and and you
know i would probably argue that's not
even a fair statement all the way but i
know what you're saying and i will say
i agree with you
i i don't know every time they were down
in a bad spot last night did you ever
doubt that tannehill and them weren't
gonna make the drive or he wasn't gonna
make the throw i think there i think
there is a different aura about him i
think it's you know one we see with
players from time to time when you
finally get to a place where
man you know i'm comfortable they
understand how i work i understand how
they work and we've formulated this
offense that works well for me as a
football player in our team
and he can go out there and play and be
loose and let it go
i
i
i didn't pick the tennessee titans to go
to the playoffs as you know we did this
on the podcast and all that
i will say after week one
actually i'll say after week one and it
was like the second drive of the game i
went uh-oh
this is that was my biggest regret if i
had to talk about any of my preseason
picks or anything like that tennessee
looks the part i was very impressed with
the way their football team looked last
night efficiency on the offensive side
of the ball got a few people banged up
on defense but you could see clowney
they got size physicality arthur smith's
got a nice system on offense they're
very multiple on the defensive side of
the ball
and
that's one i think i might regret
severely because uh they looked damn
good last night i know that was only a
two-point win but like you said earlier
i think it was it was more than that
but here's the thing yeah don't don't
throw in the towel on leaving them off
the board yet i i i think they're going
to make it but
remember what you said going into week
one the value of continuity the titans
have it the broncos are working in a new
offensive coordinator
quarterback still has had only five
starts entering this season so i think
the titans had that advantage definitely
i see it as glass half empty because
to get out of there with a skinnier
teeth
win
is unacceptable
and and you can't live like that if
you're the titans you're going to lose
too many games you will if you screw
around like that and have missed kicks
and other things that keep you from
winning the game by double digits which
they should have done now they could
have and should have still lost the game
the broncos should have had enough time
on the clock to get brandon mcmanus in
range for a game-winning field goal
which would have been the game-winner
because of the mixed missed extra point
from stephen giskowski it would have
been 17-16 the problem is
vic fangio
losing by two points had two timeouts in
his pocket that cannot be redeemed for
points and after the game he explained
why
he didn't use his timeouts and after his
explanation i'm going to tell you why
his explanation doesn't hold water but
first here's fangio explaining why i
didn't use his timeouts
well it was twofold there one their
field goal kicker had obviously been
having his problems
so i didn't want to extend the drive to
where they could get closer number one
and number two
you know we would have used the timeout
but we got the running back out of
bounds
we would have used the second timeout
but they threw an incompletion
you know which would have given us one
left when we got the ball back so that
was part of the thinking there
part of the thinking but not all of the
thinking because here's the thing by the
time they got to the point where derek
henry ran out of bounds there was an
incompletion in the end zone when the
titans went for the touchdown ryan
tannehill to aj brown aj brown didn't
catch the ball but by then it was too
late the ship had sailed i went back and
watched the end of the game this morning
and looked at the clock and figured out
when the timeout should have been called
there was a moment late in the game the
play started with 133 left on the clock
the broncos uh were defending their
29-yard line titan's handoff to derek
henry he gains 13 yards down to the 16.
that was when they should have called
the time out
the broncos should have called the time
out
that was the moment where at the as the
play ended first and 10 on the 16 127
was left when the play ended 49 seconds
were left when the next play was called
and after that play the clock's still
running
and and they have this shot of vic
fangio who i think was trying to give
off the bill belichick at the end of
super bowl 49 demeanor like i'm just
gonna not
do anything yeah and let them screw it
up right right
and after 12 seconds of that mike frable
decided well i better call a timeout
because i i'm going to screw around and
run out of time here we're going for the
end zone we're not settling for a field
goal because the guy may miss it yeah
but but that was the those two plays
not calling the timeout when the clock
went from 127 to 49 and then letting
another 12 seconds bleed off before
vrable took the time out those are the
two moments
where
fangio should have instantly called
timeout and all other things being equal
and i know that things may have been
different if the timeouts have been
called but all other things being equal
there would have been a minute and seven
seconds left when the broncos got the
ball after the field goal try right all
other things equal i went back and did
it and cross-referenced it and did the
math 107. and when you look at how close
they got with 17 seconds yeah they would
you give them another 50 seconds
they're gonna have a chance most likely
for brandon mcmanus to win the game yeah
it's it i will say i don't think it's an
easy decision uh i would have liked to
have seen them called the timeouts as
well you know even that and if i'm i'm
trying to think i'm remembering right
here because i you know it was late and
i was like dozing in and out and going
like hey come on chris wake your butt up
stay awake here but he also wastes one
of the timeouts with a pretty bad
challenge right earlier in the second
half where he
he had all three he had all three times
okay sorry i guess i'm thinking of early
in the first half the the challenge
there was a there was a challenge that
made no sense no sense that's the one
that's
like five yards big deal you're putting
one of your timeouts on the line for
five yards why are you doing that that's
what you're thinking yes you're right
i'm sorry so i got that i got that
confused for some reason i thought there
was two timeouts left at the end but i i
this day and age in the nfl you know i
err on
okay if you know you're going to be down
i do air on let's let's let's give
yourself time and give your quarterback
time to go down and kick the field goal
instead of the old school oh i'm going
to wait it out and see what my defense
can do now what's a little different i
think about the scenario we saw last
night is what vic fangio brought up you
know i think he is afraid to call time
out because he's going
i
they're dangerous on offense and and
really they didn't stop tennessee very
much tennessee went up and down the
field on them so i think he's a little
scared there to go okay if i call
timeouts this might embolden them to
throw the football or do something like
that and
then we will need a touchdown to go down
and you know have to win the game that
way and i also think he's thinking like
hey they might actually push to push the
limit and throw the ball and stop the
clock anyways here because they might
not trust goskowski to make this field
goal they have to go for the end zone
either way so
as much as i would have liked to have
seen him call the timeout i can't sit
here on a tuesday and just go
gosh that was stupid or whatever it was
you know that's what i said at the end
of the rams cowboys game when mccarthy
didn't kick the field goal to make it 20
20. i thought that was stupid this one i
just go hey i would have done it the
other way but i understand where at
least where he's coming from on this
especially with the way guskowski was
hitting the ball
but you know the argument he didn't want
to give them enough time to get closer
they got closer they're on the 16. the
moment he should have called the first
time that's enough they were in extra
point reigns yeah right plus one yard
yeah so that that's where it falls apart
for me oh yeah it's not like the
difference between the 40 and the 26
it's the 30 and the 16.
that was the moment you start doing this
and that was the moment where brian
griese i think it was on the broadcast
saying right you got to use your
timeouts here at some point yeah now
here's another here's another one for
you then we're going to take a break
end of the game
the broncos
get the ball to their own 43. okay two
seconds left yep
and i did the math real quick and we're
in denver
mile high air thin air we talk all the
time about all the long field goals guys
have done in practice and yada yada 43
yard line for the snap
that's a 74-yard field goal
oh 74 ridiculous no one ever do that
look
i i put the link
in in the story that i posted this
morning about the
the failure to use the timeouts brandon
mcmanus has made a 73-yard field goal in
denver in a practice setting not just me
and my holder
but a practice snap set hold with a
defense there with fans there more fans
there than there were in the stadium
last night
why in the hell i mean
all those factors in play
why in the hell don't you try a 74-yard
field goal instead of some draw it up on
the back of a napkin throw it up in the
air and see what happens and the final
play was a joke it was drew locke
throwing the ball to a big green sea of
nothing
why not put brandon mcmanus out on the
field for a 74-yard field going with
astounded me and i know we don't want to
criticize uh our colleagues at other
networks but nobody even said hey we're
in denver this guy's kicked a 73 yarder
in practice before why aren't we at
least considering the possibility of
kicking the field goal here yeah i i
mean in denver you got to think
differently
field goal kickers are worth an extra
four or five yards and that atmosphere
or you know with with the way the
uh the air is so thin and everything
like that it certainly would have
crossed my mind it would have and now
again i
i would have liked to have known
you know
where where was mcmanus hitting at
consistently in pregame see those are
the other things that you got to take
into account should have come up that
should have come up
struggling with the long kicks right
that's what i'm saying i don't know i
don't know but i'm just saying that's
the things i would have liked to have
heard too from the telecast just to go
hey i was watching him and you know he
was 60 he was good from there but they
moved it back to 64 in pregame and it
fell apart or whatever like that and i'm
hoping vic fangio would know something
like that but it's worth the thought
always you're right i mean in that
scenario with them all the defenders
back
you know now you got you know some good
defensive lineman on that that tennessee
defensive front there like do you really
think you're gonna be able to buy time
to get everybody down there do that
i probably i would have thought of very
seriously about taking a shot at that
field goal and just seeing what happened
yeah and it's a moment too look i'm
being selfish we want that moment no
matter what happens with the kick
as a football fan
you want that crazy oddball i can't
believe they're lining up for a 74-yard
field goal the ball is placed on the 36
on the other side of the 50 for crying
out loud so that's what i was kind of
rooting for and i know the broncos
ultimately want to win the game but when
you have a guy that's made one in 73
now vic fangio wasn't the coach at the
time but you'd like to think he has an
understanding of the range that his
kicker has yeah you at least that that
the thing that struck me you could tell
by the demeanor of everyone on the
sideline it wasn't being discussed it
wasn't discussed in the booth it was
just like not not even a thought i
looked at the vic fangio post game press
conference transcript nobody asked him
did you consider kicking the field water
this is denver for crying out loud how
do you not consider it how do you not do
it that's a separate question but how
does it not even land on your radar
screen that's what amazed me yeah i i
get you but i i'm gonna err on that the
vic fangio knows more about this
situation than we do and even even when
nice if somebody asked him about it no
you're right that i think that's that's
really what we're
we're wondering or why didn't anybody
bring that up but uh this is a pretty
smart football coach i would think there
is something more to it and you know i i
would also think that's probably
something that gets asked of him today
maybe when some of the media there in
denver gets to digest the game a little
bit more and it does cross their mind
but with the mcmanus
again when he made the 70-yard or
73-yarder and done all those things too
you know again what are the elements
like was it legit was it off a t i i
don't know if i know it was i just said
it was in a practice setting with a
defense it was a snap okay i didn't know
i don't i didn't hear the defense at all
that part it was a real set it was a
live special team setting right with
more fans behind the goal post than they
were in the entire state okay sorry i
missed you on that one sorry i was
looking up stats and things like that my
fault that's all right you don't listen
to me that's funny i always break i
don't text like you do
i don't do that why i'm talk you're
talking jerk
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports